PEOPLE THE TIME TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>>> A NEW PBS AND BBC
DOCUMENTARY FOLLOWS
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVIST GRETA
THUNBERG AROUND THE WORLD AS SHE
EXPERIENCES FISTHAND THE HUMAN
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
GRETA THUNBERG, A YEAR TO CHANGE
THE WORLD, AIRS TONIGHT ON PBS.
ADRIANA DIAZ SPOKE WITH THE
TEENAGER WHO WAS AT HER
APARTMENT IN SWEDEN AS PART OF
OUR SERIES "EYE ON EARTH: OUR
PLANET IN PERIL."
>> Reporter: DOCUMENTARY CAMERAS
WERE THERE AS GRETA THUNBERG SET
SAIL ACROSS THE ATLANTIC OCEAN
IN THE FALL OF 2019.
>> I FEEL VERY WELL TODAY.
>> Reporter: THE THREE-WEEK
VOYAGE WASN'T FOR THE REASON YOU
MIGHT THINK.
>> IT MAY SOUND VERY SILLY TO
TAKE A BOAT ACROSS THE ATLANTIC,
AND OF COURSE I'M DOING THAT TO
LOWER MY CARBON FOOTPRINT OR
SOMETHING --
>> YOU'RE NOT?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THAT WOULD BE QUITE PATHETIC.
IT DOESN'T REALLY MAKE MUCH
DIFFERENCE.
BUT I'M DOING IT TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO THE PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: THE MESSAGE IS THAT
WHILE INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT, SWEEPING CHANGE NEEDS
TO COME FROM GOVERNMENTS AND
CORPORATIONS.
>> WORLD LEADERS ARE BEHAVING
LIKE CHILDREN.
SO IT FALLS ON US TO BE THE
ADULTS IN THE ROOM.
>> Reporter: AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY, THE 18-YEAR-OLD
PUSHES LEADERS TO FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE POINTING TO THE PANDEMIC
AS A MODEL FOR SWIFT ACTION.
ANY LESSON LEARNED THAT WE COULD
APPLY TO ENVIRONMENTALISM?
>> WE CAN'T TREAT SOMETHING LIKE
A CRISIS ONCE WE DECIDE TO DO
IT.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN WHAT CAN BE
ACHIEVED WHEN WE PUT RESOURCES
INTO SCIENCE.
VACCINES WERE DEVELOPED AT
RECORD SPEED.
SO THE SCIENCE IS NOT THE THING
THAT'S HOLDING US BACK.
[ CHANTS ]
>> Reporter: WHILE SHE MAY BE
THE BEST-KNOWN CLIMATE CHANGE
ACTIVIST IN THE WORLD, SHE IS
JUST ONE OF A WHOLE GENERATION
OF YOUNG ENVIRONMENTALISTS WHO
REFUSE TO BACK DOWN.
>> WE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE GOING TO BE AFFECTED THE
MOST BY THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
WE WILL ACTUALLY BE AROUND WHEN
THE WORST CONSEQUENCES WILL
START T